tiflis fast jeden abend gehirn sind
demo für die ukraine tausende georgier
sind dabei auch slawo artjom und alex
sie sind allerdings russen am parlament
liegen berge von spenden es ist der
treffpunkt für ukraine sympathisanten
und das sind doch sie
hat schon alle brücken hinter sich
abgebrochen aber slave und alex bitten
und sie unkenntlich zu machen sie
fürchten um ihre familien zu hause und
und probleme hier alle drei flohen
überstürzt vikings regime mit
kriegsbeginn noch autoritärer wurde
solche demos können als straftat gelten
solche schilder auch russland sei krank
[Applaus]
ich schäme mich für das was in meinem
land passiert in dem land das ich liebe
und ich schäme mich dafür dass nun
ukraine in banken bunkern schutz suchen
müssen
meine freunde im ausland fragen mich
warum protestiert ihr nicht ganz groß
sie vergessen dass wir nicht in einem
demokratischen land sind die leute
werden bedroht selbst wenn du so was
trägst kannst du verhaftet werden
sie wissen wovon sie sprechen der
unabhängige journalist alex wurde auf
einer demo verhaftet trotz klarer presse
limitierung slave muss mit bis zu 15
jahren rechnen für dieses foto und den
post nein zum krieg
atrium hat nur noch das was er am leibe
trägt er floh war vor seinem haus die
polizei wartete aber seine webseite
funktioniert noch dort und auf telegramm
zeigt der rund 50.000 followern
unbequemes russische bürger die
abgeführt werden weil sie für den
frieden demonstrieren oder die grundlos
geschlagen werden
doch auch im internet wird die freiheit
weiter eingeschränkt die polizei schickt
nun sogar handys bei kontrolle
was verboten rechtlosen gegenüber dem
wir reden nicht mehr über ein freies
russland das ist eine voll entwickelte
diktatur
militärzensur ist du darfst den krieg
nicht mehr krieg nennen
du darfst nicht mehr gegen die regierung
die leute werden verfolgt verhaftet
viele verlassen das land
tiflis in georgien
schon immer ein südländischer traum für
russen sie sind wichtig für die
tourismusindustrie
sie dürfen ein reisen ohne visum man
spricht hier viel russisch
doch in den letzten tagen kamen rund
20.000 russen aus ganz anderen gründen
als sonst sie stehen nun schlange um
georgische sim karten sie richten sich
ein auf längere aufenthalte so auch
slawen und alex es wird nicht leicht sie
bekommen schon kein geld mehr am
automaten und alex erklärt einem freund
in russland an telefon das zuhause nur
gefängnis auf ihn wartet und hier auch
kein einfaches leben
ich suche eine arbeit es ist sehr schwer
zurzeit auch eine wohnung zu finden
sind so viele russen hier
die beiden sind erst 20 sie telefonieren
oft nach hause ihre mütter drängten sie
ins exil erzählen sie sie fürchteten die
repressionen den wirtschaftskollaps und
einen neuen wehrdienstes putin regimes
kurz nach kriegsbeginn schaffte slawisch
mutter fakt
innerhalb einer halben stunde schickte
sie mir ein flugticket
sie fragte mich noch nicht mal
es sei die richtige zeit zu gehen meinte
sie
meine eltern sagten mir du kannst von
georgien aus in freiheit mehr gutes tun
als zu hause im gefängnis
sie sind raus aus russland aber nicht im
kopf
mein vater schrieb mir ich solle mal
nicht betrunken werden von der ganzen
freiheit in der luft hier
wir sind so mitgenommen durch diese
erste kriegswoche ich kann mich gar
nicht frei fühlen
seit kriegsbeginn zeigen georgier mehr
sympathien für die ukraine verlangen
sanktionen doch noch will die regierung
da nicht mitziehen ihr steckt die furcht
vor russland noch in den knochen vom
krieg 2008
damals hatten russische panzer auf
georgisches staatsgebiet zum schutz
einer pro russischen minderheit dieses
aus moskau doch es spielte auch eine
rolle dass georgien sich damals gen
westen orientierte bis heute ist der
konflikt nicht gelöst nur eingefroren
teile des georgischen staatsgebietes
sind weiter unter russischer kontrolle
eine eu und nato mitgliedschaft damit
praktisch unmöglich
wiederholt sich die geschichte
der krieg von 2008 zeigt wie aggressiv
russland mit uns umgeht und jetzt sieht
man das gleiche szenario in der ukraine
das ist nicht fair russland hat einen
teil georgiens besetzt und jetzt machen
sie das gleiche mit der ukraine
vergesst nicht ihr seid hier nur zu gast
mahnen ein paar junge russen vor dem
parlament in tiflis denn das verhältnis
zu ihrem georgischen gastgebern ist
mindestens zu spät ich aber russen die
biathlon alex und slawen gegen den krieg
protestieren wollen können das nur hier
und da noch fehlt ihre stimme zu hause
dabei wäre es so wichtig dass der
klemmung gerade ihre stimmen
[Applaus]